les chrysanthèmes à pomponnettes la star
des cimetières du mois de novembre
coloré et robuste c'est ce qui se vend
le plus pour fleurir les tombes à la
toussaint maryvonne et son mari ne se
sont pas trompés les quatre j'ai choisi
des chrysanthèmes ben voyons avec les
couleurs qui me plaisait avec des
boutons pour que ça puisse durer plus
longtemps possible puisque effectivement
on ne passe de façon tout à fait
ponctuel sur les tombes et que c'est
bien de faire poursuivre notre présence
et l'affection qu'on a pour les êtres
qui nous ont quittés de façon prolongée
c'est chrysanthèmes sont locaux ils
viennent tout droit d'un producteur de
mantes-la-jolie avec le pont de cette
année la vente s'est répandu sur toute
la semaine ici on prévoit même d'en
vendre encore la semaine prochaine et
aujourd'hui on vend beaucoup d'autres
plantes aussi le chrysanthème n'est plus
la plante principal pour la tout ça vous
avez des hellébores donc les hellébores
c'est ce qu'on appelle la rose de noël
et en fin de compte c'est une plante qui
va tenir tout l'hiver qui gèle pas donc
aujourd'hui les gens sont les intérêts
c'est justement sur des plantes qui
n'ont pas gelez qui vont fleurir tout
l'hiver si d'autres blancs tout aussi
robuste se vendent aussi comme les
bruyères ou des petites jardinières
composé spécialement pour l'occasion
les chrysanthèmes reste les plantes les
plus traditionnels
quant au choix de la couleur il est lui
très personnelle de couleur jaune de
couleur claire certes quand ma compagne
étaient tous y vantent ses seuls fleurs
qu'elle aimait donc comme elle a disparu
bas tous les ans je le fais pas pour
souvenir pour gêner d'après
l'interprofession des horticulteurs et
fleuristes 72% des plantes achetées pour
la toussaint en 2018 étaient des
chrysanthèmes